we're here with jane krakowski the
amazing host of name that tune as well
as oh my god a lifetime a resume a cv
of the angels and gods i mean how long
how european of you a cv right i love
that and it's like latin and i can't
even say what it means i just know it
means resume in a in latin
like what's your cv
you know i didn't learn that until like
really late in life that a cv was also a
resume because it's such a european term
is it yeah i just i
i i all i know is i think it's latin all
right for resume for civilian subversive
god see there you go
well name that tune is such an iconic
institution yeah um i did some research
it started as a radio show in the 50s
1952
and then became a franchise television
show in the 70s and now with your
esteemed iteration that launched in 2021
um how are you liking it i mean it's
such a it is an institution
it is and i you know when i heard it was
being rebooted i love the show from my
childhood which i guess would be the 70s
iteration
in the 80s right yep kathy lee gifford
singing some of this who is kathy lee
johnson
great trivia right there that's great
trivia that is exactly right and so i
just was i remember
i grew up in a very musical household
and i remember watching the show in my
childhood and all of my family trying to
guess what the tune was and as few notes
as we could as you do on the show and i
was always in love with it so when i
heard they were rebooting and i was like
i'd love to do that i think it's a good
match for me and i love music and i have
so much fun hosting this show i'm
enjoying it so much i love randy jackson
i don't know if you know him he's
amazing not personally but
and
i
have been watching the show and it is
addictive
you
it doesn't it doesn't surprise me that
it is a
name or an iconic
show that matriculates into wanting to
play it in real life but you watch the
show and you i can't turn it off it's
like i'm like i want to get the next one
what's the next one going to be it's so
fun
yeah i love that and i also i'm just a
game person i love playing games i love
going to game nights at friends houses
um and i feel like i get that invested
with all the contestants that come on
too i find myself rooting for them and
really hoping that they'll get it you
know as host you have all the like here
i have all the answers on the card so
it's a lot easier for me but i feel like
i find what it was unexpected of being
host was that i found myself really
rooting for the contestants to win as
much money as they could when they come
on i totally understand and as you're
watching it it is just the best show you
just play along with it you can't get
enough it really is addictive
um now
you
did um schmegadoon
um
i love it
i love it and well i mean god there's so
many incredible people in that cast
including ariana dubose newly oscar
winner arianna davis
[Applause]
well
it's funny that you mentioned that
because i actually brought a clip to
show you okay
i mean rita moreno won the academy award
you deserve it too period
oh my god i'm gonna cry
thank you
oh my god i'm really crying you guys
this is terrible i do because you put
all of that work into it years of effort
and a triple threat there's so much that
you accomplish in this movie it is the
most firing electric performance i have
seen
in my life let alone in the last several
years you are a revelation in this movie
as anita
she was so beautiful
what was she like to work with
well so wonderful i knew her
before then through the broadway
community yeah um yes of course i mean
you have been involved with for as long
as i know and that's where she came
right it's one of my it's obviously one
of my first loves and it's why i love
doing schneika doom because it sort of
brought the world of musical theater to
apple tv plus but um ariana is also
amazing in shnegaden she's just an
electrifying talent and i'm so happy for
her and we've been texting through her
entire really like award-winning run you
know the whole lead-up just checking in
like how you doing like we're all just
so proud of her i've schmikadoon has
some really wonderfully acclaimed people
in it but they're also the nicest cast
i've ever worked with everybody is on a
group text and everyone is rooting for
the other person so
entirely supportive um and that's rare
for a show i think it's because we
filmed schmigadoon during the pandemic
we all had to quarantine together we all
it was it was very much like the
old-fashioned musical were like let's
get up let's get a barn and put on a
show it kind of felt like even though
it's a major television show
[Music]